hello everyone hello yay this is a very
happy audience I like this so thank you
very much for coming
greatly appreciate you taking some time
to learn some very cool stuff I'm here
to talk about this new ish
cross-platform mobile application
framework called fabulous but before I
dig into fabulous I want to talk design
patterns oh okay yeah probably worth
talking design pads so who knows the MV
something design patterns MVC MVP yeah
you know these come things so who's a
mobile developer anyway who actually
builds mobile apps it's kind of the
front rows the mobile developers and
they kind of go backwards okay that's
cool mobile developers do you build iOS
Android yep okay
both Swift objective-c so really nice
fine who's got Windows Phone come on Wow
yeah who's will has phone still works
and yeah okay so who uses xamarin and I
was here earlier saw some stuff on
xamarin ok cool react native anyone
flutter okay okay cool so probably a lot
of you have seen these various patterns
so MVC for example is the pattern for
iOS MVP was one the patterns for Android
mvvm is now becoming the android pattern
and is big in the window space so MVC
you have a model you have a view you
have a controller this was one of the
original UI patterns from 30-something
years ago they aim behind this pattern
is to try and separate out your code
separate your model logic from your view
but in Nice separation of concerns make
your model testable make it easy easy to
break your code apart even though
there's an old pattern MVC very big in
iOS you create a UI view controller yeah
the controller part is in the name of
the classes and you get this nice
separation between storyboard which is
just pure design surface a controller
and a model and then in your MVC project
your view low stager from the model the
controller sets the middle there's some
orchestration
talk back forward and overtime obviously
became MVP model-view-presenter which
broke the coupling between the viewer
not you everything gets routed through
the presenter
Hugo's presenter got the model model
presented actively since they see the
siloxane Android though it's falling out
of favor in favor of mvvm the model view
viewmodel and the various incarnations
of this including MVP vm and other
random combinations of M's and peace
movies the idea of mvvm use it in
xamarin if it always here for looses
talk just now you have the model you
have the view you have this view model
in between and have a binding layer so
this really breaks that link between the
view and the view model it's not
hard-coded the view does not know about
the view model it has loosely coupled
binding to things by name it's all very
string Beit is all very loosely coupled
now these are all great patterns these
are patterns that have been around for
decades and these are patterns that when
done well are very very good but the
problem is these patterns lead to
complexity in your apps which means when
they're bad they are very very bad and
it's very very easy to do a very bad job
it is very very easy to screw up mvvm I
know I used to do it all the time I got
better but I used to do it and the
biggest problem comes down to quite
simply where is the state in your app
you have state this is the state of the
system it is all the data inside your
app but where does that live so where
should it live in mvvm where should your
state live this is a question you can
answer
model model but what if the models
backed by a database should it live in
the database does that mean lived in the
model and the database in memory but
also memory also on disk maybe in the
cloud what if you have typing into a
name field you have a view for example
you're typing into a name field and that
data fails validation does it live in
the view doesn't live in the view model
have you already put in the model but
failed validation where is the state
and when you start implementing multiple
pages multiple models across your app
are nested models my model has lots of
other models inside it you end up in
this situation where you don't know
where the state is so who's built an app
mobile app desktop out whatever and
they've had a test to come over to them
and say I found a bug in your app and
you can't for life you reproduce it
you had that yes usually the biggest
problem is getting your version of the
system
into the same state as their version of
the system and sometimes you can follow
the exact steps the tester gives you and
you don't reproduce the bug because
although this part over here the state
is the same over here it's not because
of some other change around the state
that you don't know of so you can easy
enough for this horrible mess of what
state do I need my repositories in from
using any kind of repositories what I
think my models in my view models my
views recreate these issues is painful
you also have problems around race
conditions are we all happy with race
conditions ok few hands okay for the
Vosges those who don't know race
conditions a race condition is where
multiple threads try to do something on
some data and you end up with an
unexpected result so imagine you have a
function to increment a number so this
function you call it it reads a number
from a field one increments the number
two writes the number back down to if I
call this twice what number would I
expect yes true after calling up from
two if I call it twice you go three
therefore yes it's always a smartass but
that's not always true because if I call
this on two threads thread one comes in
rings the number one for a two comes in
waits a number one thread one increment
number two thread two income is a number
two thread one writes number down to
throw - rezznor - we've gone from one to
two in though caught it twice that's
kind of your basic canonical race
conditioner and when you have multiple
models and you have multiple bits of
states and your models are interacting
with the user interface on the UI thread
and the react they're interacting with
the network they're interacting with the
operating system through push
notification so other kind of
notifications they're interacting with
who knows what eight synchronously you
run this risk of race conditions and
suddenly you've got a bug and you can't
reproduce the state of the bug because
you don't know when the data has come
from here or from the Year wire from
whatever and you're in this horrible
mess so state it's not a good thing so
is there a better way wouldn't it be
good if we have fixed these problems of
state if we can fix these race
conditions isn't what do we get there's
a better way a way that helps us fall
into a pit of success rather than fall
into a pit of failure and there is with
envy you it's another of these MV star
patterns but this one's good
it's called model view update who's
heard of em for you okay few hands who's
sort of Elm few more hands yes
Elm is kind of the canonical mvu
architecture on this the initial
frameworks L miss of web based framework
that uses mvu Model View update as the
way of doing things and this framework
has now start fall out on a lot of other
places and the principles of envy you
kind of seem a bit weird when you first
read about them but they do make a lot
of sense so the first thing you have is
you have an immutable model by a mutable
I mean your model cannot change it is
fixed the data cannot change ideally you
want to build this with a programming
language or an architect's model which
blocks you from changing things now it's
a few phases going what do you mean you
can't change the model I need to do
things we'll get to that you then have a
message multiple different types of
message which could optionally have data
and these messages indicate that a
change of state needs to take place okay
so we have a model but can't change and
the message that says please change what
do we do well then we have an update
function and what this update function
does is it gives you a brand new model
and then you have a view function that
takes that brand new model and renders
it on screen still sounding a bit
weird isn't there so let's just take a
little bit deeper so the idea behind
your model is your model is the entire
state of the system it is the golden
source of state it is the state it is in
this one model just one no more this
model can be nested but your model
there's one of them it is the golden
state of your system and because there's
one model you can persist this model you
can see rise it's Jason you can log it
to some kind of an online logging
service like application insights or any
kind of other web-based monitoring
system you can save the date of places
you don't manage stuff with it because
there's one of them and it never ever
changes totally immutable cannot change
because it cannot change other threads
can do over the hell they like they
cannot change your model there's no race
conditions and then every single app
every single mvu based application web
mobile desktop whatever has a single
instance of the model as its state one
instance that is the state you then have
this message as message says I need the
state of the system to change and this
can actually have some kind of data
associated now these messages can come
from the UI I tap a button it raises a
message it can come from the network you
make a call the results come back here
is some data it comes as a message
you come from a push notification
anything you like anything that says the
state needs to change comes as a message
and then all these messages get routed
through an update function and this is a
function so yep we're going to be
talking functional programming here this
is a function that takes the model takes
the golden source the one single model
that is the entire state of your system
takes the message and what it will do is
it will create a brand new model that is
a deep copy of your original model deep
copy every single field is copied of
every single sub item in the model
absolutely everything is deeply copied
with the exception of anything that
needs to change based off your message
so you end up with is totally brand new
model because your model is immutable
brand new model with differences to
okay completely separate object you
think about it in terms of boring basic
computer science this one sits in this
block of memory brand-new one in this
block of memory completely separate
objects okay
and this update function it's completely
synchronous it's called a one thread of
one thread only and at the end of this
update function the new model that comes
out becomes the golden source the
ultimate state of your system so because
of the limitations of this architecture
you have this golden source go into an
update function with a message a new
golden source comes out you know that's
this goal the source can only ever
change in the update function this is
what your state looks like okay and this
new golden source of state is then
passed to a view function and this takes
your model the golden source of state
and returns a virtual UI and this
becomes the UI you see on-screen and
this is called automatically after the
update and again is synchronous now a
virtual UI sounds a bit weird but a
virtue UI is essentially a
representation of the user interface
okay
and when you call this view function you
get back a complete user interface but a
virtual version of it and that virtual
version is compared to the real user
interface by your mvu framework and any
difference is a copied over so it just
copies the differences you can think of
a virtual virtual UI like HTML HTML is
text it's just text a real UI is buttons
and pictures and widgets and annoying
pop-ups asking you to subscribe but the
virtue UI is just text ok that text is
really lightweight to create the real
you is heavyweight from your view
function you create a virtual UI this is
lightweight it doesn't create expensive
UI objects it's just very simple
lightweight representations and then
when this gets applied to your user
interface
it looks for differences and copies it
over now that's all kind of quite
complicated so let's just put this in
pictures to make it a little bit easier
so any kind of a canonical mvu app you
have a model here's my model it's purple
this is my golden stage of my system
it's my one model immutable count
one my app starts there's my view
function and it renders on screen my
view returns a label this label has the
text set to the value of count it says 1
this is my initial State
I then receive a message called
increment and this to come from tapping
a button for example so my model in
mutual model and my message goes into my
update function and I get a brand new
model coming out which is a deep copy of
the data except its increment in my
count for mom to my old bottle thrown
away we don't want you anymore go away
done been my new model becomes the
Golden State golden sauce my system the
gold source of state into my view then
the view spits out a virtual UI that
says I need a label with the text of to
the framework looks at the virtual UI
label Texan 2 looks the real UI label
text of 1 goes Texas different copies
the text I end up with 2 on screen so
that's got the basic most simplistic
architecture of an MV new app ok
and because this update is synchronous I
can chain him I never have that raised
condition where two different threads
come into the same number hit the race
condition and we get one increment the
update is the only place you can make
changes and this happens synchronously
the framework keeps that synchronously
so you never have to worry about race
Commission's ok and if those you've done
react native probably in something
similar as a similar kind of flow this
is say user now she's not so other
places so why do we do this why do we
use MBU well having this single source
of truth makes it really easy to track
what's going on in our app we know that
this model is the entire state of the
system we can catch it we can save it we
can store it imagine if a tester comes
to you and says I've got this problem I
found this bug here's the thing you can
capture their stay deploy their stay and
you entire app can resume exactly the
same point at which their their app was
one here even just things like
restarting an app you close that you
reopen it because you can save the state
your app will go back to the exactly
same UI so who here has had to do that
with an app you've had
persist the state of an app and then
when the app restarts reload the state
and then step through the UI to get to
the same spot let's do that yeah you
don't have to do that then for you just
say for the state reload the state when
there was Reba voi exactly how you
wanted it you get that kind of stuff for
free that ability to return to any point
no roads conditions
you can't update your state except in
one place or one thread narrows
conditions obviously you can write bad
coding the coding implement race
conditions in another way but the
framework blocks you from doing dumb
things it's pretty cool and it's much
easier to debug them because it's one
state one place say the state you can
keep track of State message state
message state message and then replay
that you can build integration tests
with them the Z from their variants of
mvu which has which have time travel
debugging so imagine that a little
slider for time you can slide back and
forward as you see the state of
replication over time it's pretty sexy
and the whole thing is easier to unit
test because you have one place the
state can change I keep saying this
because it's true one place so you can
write unit test that says with this day
and this message I expect this and you
can go through every iteration of
messages and models that could happen in
your app and building these unit tests
and then you do the same thing for your
view you can go through every single
model that you might have after an
update and test what the virtue you why
is that comes out the view function
returns a virtual UI not a real new I it
is not UI objects doesn't require UI
thread it is a virtual representation
that you can unit test so you can write
unit tests against your view none of
this expensive UI testing you're not
launching an app that actually in
interacting with the Apple clicking
buttons you can do it all for unit
testing which is phenomenal
so that's mvu nice bit of background
what is fabulous
well fabulous is as you'd expect and in
be friendly it's a cross-platform mvu
framework it is open source community
LED cross-platform app framework it's
all based off MV you completely open
source got a really strong community who
are working on it and it's not just
mobile
it supports desktop and he's a
well-established language
well-established tools it's not using
anything new and shiny that's got bugs
this is using well-established
battle-hardened stuff a second bill for
iOS I can go for Android him to scrape
mobile or desktop Mac Windows Linux all
the things I can build them even some
TVs it can run on it's pretty cool and
what you get out of it when thinking
about mobile it's a 100% native app and
when I say hundreds at native app I mean
it is built using the tool chains
provided by the people who actually make
the phones it is compiled down to Java
with the Android SDK it is compiled to
LLVM byte code that runs on iOS using
the Xcode tool chains it's fully native
in fact fabulous it's got little thin
wrappers around the entire native SDKs
so everything is fully native the
controls are fully native everything you
see on screen native look native feel
and much more important native
accessibility is something people can
neglect when think about mobile apps so
oh here's a new shiny framework which
has got uses a drawing engine to draw
all the things on the screen to draw
virtual buttons it's like great ok how
does it work with the screen reader oh
we haven't done that bit yet well sorry
where is this where you have the amazing
accessibility tools built in things on
iOS you get that for free with fabulous
because it uses the native controls and
a hundred percent native API access the
entire suite of api's is available asana
fabulous app iOS releases iOS 13 with an
X tiny shiny for doing a our kit bazinga
things whatever it brings out you can
have that with fabulous hundred some
appliances and that's without having to
drop down into Objective C or send
messages and all the other weird and
wacky ways that some variants of
cross-platform coding have to do so
that's kind of me waffling on but we're
engineers right
do you like code yeah let's see some
code let's actually see some code so
when my screen starts doing its thing
hello computer yay so I'm going to spin
up it works
they're very cool so this is some of my
first canonical mvu fabulous app so what
have I got here I have got Windows has
made this annoying update to the pen
thing which is very very slow so what
have I got here I have a model this is
my model and it contains a count which
is an int this particular datatype is a
record it is immutable this is not a
property that I can change it's set when
the objects created cannot be changed
and then have a message increment I'm
going to increment it fair enough and
then when I initialize my code I
initialize it the model has a count of 0
ok that's my model I have my update
function takes the message the model if
a mess is increment this syntax here
says copy the model deep copy all the
fields and return it but set the count
to be the original model can +1 so this
creates that deep copy this is that
model completely copied over field by
field except when when it gets the count
field which herbs in this example is any
field when it gets the count field
instead of copying that set it to be the
old count plus 1 that's my entire
business logic done ok
and then my UI logic my entire UI this
here so this is the completely why I've
got my view function it takes the model
returns a content page this is the
fabulous way of saying it is a page with
some content in it kind of name gives it
away Aloha my content is a thing called
a stack layout which as you can imagine
is a layout where we stack things so
fabless is a whole load of layouts out
the box stacks grids flex boxes for
those on the off sort of a webbing frame
of mind will have that kind of stuff I
have a stack layout my set layer some
children the first child is a label
and this has got the text set to be the
model count so this label shows the
count tap the button think when it can't
get submitted to I then have a button
and this button is wired up to dispatch
the increment message so when I tap this
button it dispatches the in current
message that Ling goes to the update
function where all the messages are
process synchronously the update
function will then increment the value
of the count deep copy the model
increment the count cause the view
function view function creates a brand
new virtual UI the framework will then
look at the new virtual UI look at the
actual UI see that the value the value
of the label the text label has changed
update the label so let's just give my
secrets so if the visor is playing play
nicely this should kick off and we
should see it in action while this is
building for those who don't know I'm
using Microsoft Visual Studio yeah who
uses Visual Studio
ah everybody more or less yes
so Visual Studio is the environment I
use but a fabulous app and in finish you
know you have a solution which is
basically a bucket containing projects
and each project is a thing that spits
out an output of some description okay
so one of the outputs that spits out is
this Android app hello fabulous top
Android this is an Android app an actual
apk containing all my Android gubbins
now anyone who's built any Android apps
before will know you have a main
activity you have a resources folder
with your layouts and images and XML and
all the other gump that you need yeah so
this is using an identical API to
Android if I was building an Android app
with Java I'm just doing it inside here
fabulous but I have the same kind of
structure and say this APK it goes
through the standards and with build
process and gets JA
signed and zipper lines and all those
other horrible things that take a
annoying amount of time but it gets all
that and we have an iOS up here allow us
mo zhee bit iOS recognize map delegate
analyze that catalog again it's the same
as an iOS app you would build with
objective-c it's just a built-in side
fabulous now the astute amongst you who
have built i/o app iOS apps before will
notice I'm on Windows and I'm building
an iOS app it's a little bit naughty
Apple don't want me to do that well
Apple have rules Apple have said if you
want to build an iOS app you have to do
it on our Mac an apple have done this
because Apple loves money and they want
you to spend money on shiny shiny toys
and it's true if you want to build a
fabulous iOS up you have to have a Mac
somewhere doesn't have to be here you
don't have to code on a Mac you just
have to be able to connect to a Mac
somewhere that Mac can be of CO P your
computer you can do this on vision if a
Mac it can be on your own network it can
mean the cloud if you want to doesn't
matter this will connect to a Mac it'll
copy the code over to the Mac it will
run all the Xcode Xcode toolchain do all
them Mac magical stuff that makes Apple
happy and they'll send the code back now
if your Mac is on the same Wi-Fi network
as your phone you can debug on your
phone the same as you do on Xcode if
your Mac is up in the cloud and you
can't put on the same Wi-Fi network week
even screen share the max in the iOS
simulator back to Windows if you want to
so as long as you can connect your Mac
somewhere in the world you can build iOS
apps that's pretty cool and the last
thing I have here is I have this hello
fabulous project this is my
cross-platform code so this is my
fabulous app this is where my model
might view my update and all my bits and
pieces live when this gets built this
gets shared between iOS and Android now
I've said you can get a hundred set
native API access and this is completely
true
obviously if I'm writing code that
shared between iOS and Android I can't
build the code to crater NS data on
Android I can't build code to create an
Android background service on iOS I
can't do this kind of thing so what I
can do is I can put that code inside the
android project or the iOS project or
create a brand-new project that's
Android based ios-based put the platform
specific code in there and then using
various techniques which we'll look at
later
link it back to my cross-platform code
so I've got that 100% native API surface
abstracted away into the various
different projects that need it which is
very very cool cool so that's finished
let's just spin up visor and here we
have my app unless you can imagine well
that's happening when the number goes up
yeah I built an app isn't this awesome I
built an app to count things
look at me I'm amazing so literally
we've got what are we down to 46 so that
all in all there's about fifty five
lines of code and that's the entirety of
all the app stuff that I need to get
this working to get the UI built which
is pretty nice pretty small now and at
the inquisitor number it's not very
useful is it we should decrement the
number as well that will make it really
useful yeah so let's do that now again
normally as a developer I would then
kill the app write the code rebuild the
app redeploy the app get bored while
Android does its thing go and get some
coffee come back an hour later we'll
have you but fabulous is far too
fabulous to enforce now so what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna spin up where
are we just gonna spin up the fabulous
watcher in the background and I'm just
gonna leave my at running let's edit
some code let's in here let's add the
decrement message type yay I then need
to handle this message type here so
let's just copy and paste this you'll
notice very nicely though if you can
sake you see the little green squiggly
under the message
this is a compiler telling me you've got
another message you know you're not do
anything with it the compiler is
reminding me that I may have forgotten
to put a message in there isn't that
nice
we like compilers like this this is why
this is a fabulous so I pasted this in
and I say right well it doesn't have the
increment obviously it has to be
decrement and let's make that to be
minus one and then let's just copy and
paste the button copy this drop this in
here
change the speed decrement and then
change this and let's just save this now
after I've saved this Oh things
happening so behind the scenes
especially look at my code yeah the
codes changed and it will kick off a
whole load internal compiler services to
recompile the code and then push you
back up to my device now this particular
version has a small bug in it it seems
to recompile four or five times the
first time around but it's pretty good
and that thing gets pushed up the device
and sir if I flip back to my device
there you go haven't even stopped it
live update I've got two buttons there
it's pretty cool first time that happens
takes a few seconds after that it gets a
little bit quicker so if I want to go
hid in here and change this text color
to be red save that I then zip back give
that a second that should then they go
it's ready pretty quick and the device
I'm running this on is a black view a 7
it is a 50-pound Android device so if
you had to do that on a real grown-up
device that's fast and not rubbish and
cheap because your company won't buy you
an Android phone if it is on a fast
device it actually happens pretty much
instantaneously so the demos I've seen
on a top-of-the-range google pixel phone
it can get the update happening like a
third of a second that's pretty sweet
isn't it so that's kind of the canonical
F sharp lab canonical fabulous code demo
give it home secrecy so how does it all
work I mean that's all great but well
how does the magic happen how does it
all work well
you get to look at my daughter for a
second there we go
so as the various student run in the
front of the room said this is all
powered by f-sharp
who loves f-sharp ya few hands there
this is what we like to say yes so for
those who don't know F sharp F sharp is
what is called a functional first
programming language so it is a
functional programming language but also
supports object-oriented code to allow
it to interrupt with other languages
that are object-oriented based and it's
cross-platform sits on top of dotnet
Blahnik or what have you
Mac Windows Linux iOS Android so it's a
functional programming language that
runs everywhere it's a very powerful
function programming language and it's
fully dotnet compatible so if you're
used to using dotnet you can use F sharp
all those lovely dotnet libraries that
you know and you love Jason dotnet for
example the best Jason logo in the world
yeah just works all donut standard
compliant so all your love you don't
need standard libraries will work your
c-sharp code you can package up it will
work hell you can even build vb.net
libraries and they would probably work
if you feel so inclined but there's a
huge swathe of NuGet packages and other
bits and pieces you can use with F show
which is fantastic
f shops also fully open source and as a
community driven Microsoft powered
language what I mean by that is it is
open source it's open to community
contributions there's a whole F sharp
foundation that supports it but
Microsoft reserves just a little bit of
control simply because it is a dotnet
language so it needs to work with
the.net capabilities it needs to work
the latest parts of donair standard so
it's kind of let the community build
their awesomeness and we'll just keep
them on the path that we have to keep
them one to keep backwards compatibility
I left sharp you can use it everywhere
you can absolutely use it everywhere so
if you log if you love em for you but
you're a web developer fable it's an
Elvish Elm based
MV you still architecture doing the same
kind of thing for the web this is a
whole stack of tools you can use with
f-sharp to cross any platform you want
front-end back-end you want to build
functions up in the cloud as your
functions and f-sharp with an F fabulous
mobile front end whatever it just works
some amazing language and
it's the kind of language where whenever
people I know started using it after
using an anger for a short period of
time they never want to go back it is a
phenomenal languages so terse so nice
and it's functional first say you use
functional programming paradigms to
build everything it's when you first
start using it you're pretty much going
what that at all but I have to get your
head around it it is fantastic mat that
supports oo code means you can cut great
Interop with a framework notes that f
sharp which is not met so how does the
the mobile side of things work well for
those who are in the last session in
this room would have heard of a thing
called xamarin those who haven't it's
powered by xamarin so who knows what
slammer it is yeah most people so for
those who don't salmon is very simply
very very very thin net wrappers around
the iOS and Android SDKs existing SDKs
from Google from Apple so that way you
can build mobile apps using your dotnet
language of choice but build them in the
way that makes sense for iOS or Android
spin up the UI view controller spit up
your activity have your storyboards have
you like XML whatever you can build it
using a dollar language C sharp F sharp
because it's thin wrappers you get
hundreds of native apps your hand put
native controls the same lovely stuff I
said about fabulous and it's fully
compatible so you build your mobile apps
but instead of using nsurl session you
use botnets HTTP plan to talk under the
hood that use it as your our session but
you use HTTP client cuz that works the
iOS and Android using the native Stefan
denieth and salmon allows you to build
on Windows Mac and again just as you saw
with focus you can do iOS ones or
Windows now Zaman's got a abstraction
sits on top because if you build a
cross-platform app with xamarin out the
box you have to use storyboards an
Android XML because it's just an
underpinning ativ framework thin
wrappers so there's a thing called
salmon forms which provides a UI
abstraction that provides you with
buttons and labels and images and other
kind of widget Lee bits and pieces that
when you say I want a button
salmon form session
cool you're on iOS you get UI button
you're an Android you're an Android
widget but you want to have a label of
course iOS get you our label Android to
get Android we get textview so zaman
forms gives you 100% native apps hundred
seven native API with all the stuff that
you need but you write your code once
and it compiles down to the different
native platforms and that's what we can
do inside fabulous coz fabulous it's on
top of salmon forms so when I said in my
fabulous code I want I want to create a
label the salmon forms runtime that sits
underneath will say iOS UI label I'll
set the text to be your number Android
yeah text me so that XP on on so it kind
of just dips down to the native controls
for you and you can then have access if
you want to because any kind of
abstraction has to remove functionality
zemana forms can't give you access to
every teeny tiny little thing that ios
and android can do because they're
different some things are available on
iOS something nhave roundwood some are
very my android not on iOS so forms
gives you what does apply across both
but you can always sit down to the
native controls if you want to you've
got full access the 100% api you can go
onto there you can say i want to do this
thing for iOS or this thing for android
you have that power in salmon forms is
completely open source because it's
comes from Microsoft and what does
Microsoft really really love open-source
so much we bought github that's how much
we love it so let's do some more demos
let's do some more code let's build a
slightly more interesting so I I built a
little app to upload photos to the cloud
when I take a photo and I'll upload this
photo to the cloud because hey I work
for Microsoft and we know all about the
cloud it makes us lots of money and I
got lots of free credits for it so to
build a mobile app to do this I need
number of different things so I need my
app with the UI with a button I can tap
to take a photo I need a way to take
that photo I probably should check
network connectivity because I'm a good
developer and I know mobile often
not have network connectivity so I
should check that I have network
connectivity before I upload the photo
and then I need a way to upload that
photo to the cloud some kind of API for
doing this so here is my code for doing
this so what have I got here got a model
I've got a message my model I've got a
photo stream which is a rural stream of
data containing my photo behind the
scenes it would just be a by tourists on
them I've got this image source thing
this is a wrapper that fabulous uses to
provide the source data for an image and
this can be a stream of data it can come
from a URL come from a file on disk
whatever it's just kind of a wrap around
a source for an image allows internal
image caching God is busy flag cuz you
know what if my apps busy I probably
should show something on the UI and then
I have this save storage property which
is a stream goes to async of the unit
okay this is actually a function my safe
safe storage property is a functioning
I'll come back to how this works later
now I have this message as well this is
we need messages I've got photo taken
message of stream I've got my change
busy message of bull so this is what's
cool about the messages and mvu
architecture is you have a message type
but it can have data if you want it to
have data this is one of the powers of
functional programming this uses a thing
called a discriminated Union which is
kind of like an enum on steroids every
field in your enum can have data with it
so you can kind of treat it like an enum
and just switch on this but then pull
the data out very very powerful
construct and the model that we have
here this is an F sharp record type
after the box it is immutable it cannot
change its data to make it mutable I've
got to explicitly put the keyword
mutable on there and when you see the
keyword mutable in code that's a good
reason to reject a pull request because
someone's probably doing something wrong
so got a model I got the message okay
so when I initialize my model I
initialize my model whatever yes listen
nulls they're unfortunates one the
salmon forms limitations I kind of had
to put null there and
- and then I have my update function so
here's my update again comes the message
I match on my message lovely bit of F
sharp pattern matching their photo taken
message deep copy my model updating the
photo stream an image source if I update
change busy deep copy my model updating
is busy so again this is nice deep
copies of the data I don't have to worry
about race conditions they're all deep
copies cool giveaway wrong let's just
skip a little bit further down to my
view okay here's my view now I really
screwed up the stuff on this so here's
my key I have a grid grid in my view
grid it's a very simple layout what does
a grid have rows and columns there's one
to layout my day two in rows and columns
and I'm saying what my top road to be as
big as it can be star use all available
space my bottom row to auto size for the
content so this will give me a nice
layout we have a button at the bottom
use the size the button the big thing
that told us what I want to get to I
then would have my children to my view
I've got an image which uses the image
source the model that's seen which will
take a photo got a button room this has
got a command that does that does
something that's my button whiskery now
because I love I love giving good
feedback to the user I want to have the
screen grayed out and a little spinner
when you're busy okay this is pretty
cool now normally when you're building a
UI if you want to hide and show some
kind of busy indicator you would put the
UI component inside your UI and then set
the visibility look like a boolean flag
hide it show it okay well I don't have
to do that I can actually just remove it
completely from my UI so I can actually
say in my virtual UI if my model is busy
return a new grid with a black
background that's 50% capacity and
turn an activity indicator that sits in
the middle but only if my model is busy
if our model is not busy
do not put these in the UI and that
differential update that comes after the
view function it'll look at the UI
okay well the virtual UI has got this
green activity indicator real one
doesn't let's add the objects or virtual
one doesn't have them real one does
let's delete the objects so I can
completely structure how I build my UI
all the different components using
simple if statements I can use this kind
of boolean logic to add and remove UI
components rather than just relying on
turning visibility's are not if anyone's
done Android development will know just
if you have lots of views on screen your
app gets very very slow because Android
is not particularly efficient so the
less views you can have instead of
hiding them if you can remove them your
app gets quicker okay so that gives me
gives you my nice UI now what I want to
do is take the photo
so my command calls my take photo
function okay this is all not love
nicely asynchronous so here's my take
photo function
nice async this function now the first
thing I do is function is check where
they have network access if I don't have
network access I don't want to do
anything because this isn't this uploads
to the cloud okay now the iOS API is in
the Android API is for network access
are different completely different api's
so I could write my own code in my iOS
project my Android project to do my
funky network thing check the network
status and then feed that code into my
core project or I could use the think
examine essentials it's a bit for salmon
works in fabulous this is a bunch of
api's that give you abstraction x' over
some common things you will do on your
device things like check for network
access GPS accelerometer secure storages
and their built-in encryption
capabilities all those things are
available to me really easily so I can
say if we have network if we don't have
network access display an error one line
of code cross-platform code under the
hood using the native iOS and Android
bilities there's a nice little extension
then if I do have network access I'd
send a change busy message so this
function is running in the background
this is an asynchronous function runs in
the background
it runs dispatches this message over
here my update sits on one thread picks
up the message changes the is busy flag
spits out a brand new UI on this video
and then we come back so the next part
of code I'd do something which I'll talk
about just one second but after it's
done right at the end when everything's
finished
I change my busy back so again that
message goes in I'm on this thread here
it goes into my update function over
here it goes back in new UI comes out
so everything's serialize through the
update function every time I dispatch a
message I know they'll all go in order
to my update function wherever I am in
my code I can do that
so I want to take a photo now salmon
essentials on 40 does not yet to contain
a camera API
unfortunately so I could use the iOS and
Android camera api's which is pretty
horrible very different not particulars
but luckily because families have built
up a salmon and salmon is a
well-established framework there's a
huge amount of community contributions
this includes plugins to provide
abstractionist this was kind of the
original ideas behind essentials came
from these plugins so I can use this
plug-in here to take the photo those are
in Lucis talk early would have seen the
same plug-in in use take a photo one
long ago take a photo under the hood iOS
camera api's Android camera api's look
you see back a photo I don't have to do
this I can use the iOS API I can use the
Android API so I could put in lovely
photograph overlays I could wire in
quorum L models to do the stupid
snapchat things I love sending tons and
is whatever I want I could do that if I
want to but I don't have to I could be
much more productive one on the code get
a photo and then I dispatched another
message to my update function and I say
them okay so let's just run this see
this in in actually let's kick this off
and wait for an order to do its thing so
we've got this lovely app got iOS app
with an Android app I've got my model I
have my messages my update function
updates my model based off their photo
been taken I'm hoping my busy flag I've
got my UI parts of my UI will be removed
if my busy flag is false added if the
busy flag is true and then I've got my
lovely asynchronous function using
essentials it checks for network access
if it hasn't it like access it uses a
plug-in to launch the camera it takes a
photo does some storage saving
dispatches it and we will wait a bit
longer because Android is woefully slow
woefully slow
well that's doing its thing we'll see
this in action nice finished let's talk
about the saving of storage so if you
remember this safe storage function is a
function that was set on the model so
where does it come from and why is it a
function well the reason being is I like
to make my life hard for you I've made
my life difficult just for you because
that's the kind of nice guy I am yes
so I use Azure to save stuff because I
work for Microsoft and if I showed off
another cloud they might tell me off so
Anna has an amazing storage capability a
storage I can save table storage blob
storage work whatever blob storage is
perfect for me because I can say these
photos as a blob up to the cloud so I
decide to use blob storage now there is
a dotnet storage SDK
it is a new get package for those who
are familiar with not nap I can install
the new get package I can give it my
connection string and I can save to a
blob it's nice and easy I can do that
and because I mean I'm fabulous
f-sharp doc nap I can do that I don't
want to do it the easy way I want to do
it the hard way
and the hard way is there eyes actually
as well as a dotnet IP SDK for we have
an Android SDK we have an iOS SDK and I
thought I'd use the Android SDK because
if you're building a mobile app
chances are you may want to use a
third-party component and if your
third-party component is a cocoa pod or
an aar an IRA very poetical name if it's
one of those components you might want
to use it and if you're using a
cross-platform framework can you use
things like cocoa pods can you use jars
and the answer is with fabulous yes yes
you can
fabulous is built on top of xamarin
xamarin is thin net wrappers around the
iOS Android SDKs okay what if the people
who write those wrappers built a tool
for it and what if they give you that
tool and that's what they've done so
inside my projects here I have just make
my solution Explorer bigger zoom in
there we go
why is it the magnifier puts herself in
a really really silly place so I have
this as your storage project here good
jars folder in my jars fona is an honor
and I a are for those who haven't come
across an aar before an aar is a jar a
Java archive but one that's designed for
Android apps has got other bits and
pieces rather than Java code it's got
Android stuff in them and this access
storage Android 2 0 0 aar is the Android
SDK you could if you're building a
native Android app with Java with Kotlin
you add this to your Gradle thing and it
downloads it from the maven thing I
don't do Java so don't really know what
I'm talking about but it does the thing
when it downloads it and puts in your
app ok but I've put it in here inside
Visual Studio so what happens is when I
drop this in here into the special
project which is an Android binding
project the binder will look at that
aar look at the classes and it will
create the same thing net wrappers that
you get on with with xamarin but it'll
create them for me for this particular
library so find a zip over to the S code
for example we've got the same thing
open this is the code I can see it comes
in the output folder I can actually see
the very thin wrappers that are
generated for me
so I've got this capability to drop a
jar and use it pretty exciting stuff so
when I have this one here I got my
storage service class here this looks
like dotnet code standard F sharp code
here but under the hood this is calling
those thin wrappers around the jars so
I'm using a native Android Java library
inside my fabulous app I dropped it in
it just works
now one thing I can do if I want to is
inside this project I have this metadata
XML file this allows me to define
transformations for example I can say I
don't like the Java name spacing of
comma Microsoft I just wanted to be
Microsoft whatever I can do that I can
change return types I can change names
parameters I can even completely replace
blocks of code if I want to I have this
power to enable me to take the Java API
and make it a bit more dotnet friendly
if I feel so inclined but I take this
and using this this is thinly rap Java
code pretty sexy if I say so myself
now I wanted to use the Android one here
a bit so this is Android code on iOS I
would do the same with the cocoa pod
I'll launch a tool called objective
Sharpie behind the cocoa pod make the
same transformations if I want to use
the code so how do I take that
platform-specific code and call it from
my fabulous code well any one functional
program is probably compose things by
Punk by passing functions around slight
the functional program version
dependency injection instead of
interfaces you can pass functions around
and I can do that swim my main activity
which the Android people the room will
recognize from any Android app when I
spin up my Fabrice app I pass in a
function that function gets populated
through mark the construction of my code
and ends up assigned to my model so when
I call this function here it's composed
from the function on Android the
function of iOS so suddenly I got this
capability to really really easily
bringing code this platform-specific
into my cross-platform code I call safe
storage once the implementation exists
in two places and that then gives me
this nice app which is running here
let's hold it up
let's take a nice photo there we go
oh yeah so that little bit of code that
I created allow me to put this you I tap
the button launch the camera take the
photo show the spinner photos now being
uploaded to blob storage and to prove
that I'm not lying about it being
uploads to blob storage I come here look
at my blob storage account refresh that
there is my photo click on that in my
blob storage click on edit blob and
there you all are
isn't that beautiful yay so that little
bit of code written really nice way just
works cross-platform code
noburo platform pacific code that I
could brought in when I needed it nice
simple UI model view update no worries
about race conditions one place where my
code can change it is it is now to coin
a phrase it's fabulous absolutely
fabulous sweet so the last few minutes
wait for the screen to catch up get to
see my daughter again
yay come on there we go cool so how do
you get started you've seen this you
love it who wants to do this who's gonna
go home tonight but yeah this is what
I'd like to say few hands or hands
please so how do you get started well
the first thing have to is install
visual studio ok Windows or Mac yeah to
install visual studio so see some smirks
there sorry you have to do a visual
studio I'm afraid when you saw we just
stood out on the Mac you get all the
things if you do it on Windows you've
got to take the salmon box in the F
sharp box and that will bring in all the
things it will bring all the Android
SDKs for you select Android emulators
give you all the codes you need to talk
to iOS so from your windows box you
installed with your studio with the
salmon bits you can network to an iOS
and it will copy all this stuff over
that the Mac needs to actually build iOS
apps the only thing you have to do on a
Mac is login install Xcode through the
App Store and then run Xcode once
because Apple is incapable of
distributing software through the App
Store that you cut that you can just use
straight off without running at once to
install some extra tools and new Apple
so install that you get all the stuff
there's some templates for fabulous
those who do do netting you know stop
that new to Christ
yay got one knows doc letting you
fabulous at create the app and away you
go
so with that thank you very much that
was a very quick overview of fabulous we
looked at mvu we looked at building at
first that we needed to talk about F
sharper talked about slamming and we saw
just how fabulous this capability is
this amazing ability to build
cross-platform apps without worrying
about your state without worrying about
race conditions so I'm Jim Bennett
McLeod advocate at Microsoft I'm on
twitter at jim bob bennett please follow
me i do tweet interesting things and
everything you need a cadet ms / fab NDC
this straight to a github repo with all
the code with slides from here with a
whole load of links to all the left shop
stuff that you need all the Fabri stuff
you need
everything's open source if you want to
get involved you can we've got some nice
first issues if you want to fix bugs get
going and thank you very much for coming
thank you
[Applause]